(salsa music)
(scooter vrooming)
- What's up Believe Nation, happy weekend!
How you doing?
I wanted to share something that
I did for the wife.
Actually Nina suggested
that we make a video on this
'cause we needed something
to share with you guys
so this was her idea.
- I look very tall in here.
- It's 'cause you're on your toes.
Yep, I knew it.
I knew she was on her toes, I knew that.
Nina likes plants.
Our entire condo is full of plants,
and as soon as they get too full
she gives some away to friends
so that she can grow more plants.
Right?
- Kind of, not really.
- What?
Even today we had friends
over and she gave them
dirt to go home with.
Nina loves her plants,
and in the winter time,
it's harder because she
can't grow as much stuff.
We have a balcony outside
and she likes to grow stuff,
but in the winter obviously
you can't do that.
So, I decided to do
something special for her
and help build her a little indoor...
- Plant.
- It's not an indoor plant.
- Indoor...
- Planter, that's the
word we're looking for.
- No, we actually showed the previous one
where we asked for help
to grow my plant indoor.
- [Evan] So we've done this already?
- But now showing what you have been--
- You want to show the update?
- Yeah.
- Okay this is the update,
this is what I built.
We got the stand-up desk and at the top
Nina has her keyboard
that she plays piano on.
And then underneath we've got these
growing lights and a big grow light
and then in here she's growing her plants
that are just starting to come up.
What are you growing in here?
- [Nina] This one is the, I think it's
either cucumber or zucchini.
Cucumber or zucchini.
- [Evan] You grew these
all from seed, right?
- [Nina] Yeah.
- [Evan] It's all from seed.
- [Nina] And then this tomato,
tomato, tomato, tomato.
And kale, kale, kale, kale, kale.
And then sage, sage.
And then my avocado plant.
- [Evan] Oh look at that
thing, it's getting big.
- [Nina] Yeah.
- Why don't you stand on the trampoline?
Look, look how Nina just grew.
There you go, now you don't
have to stand on your toes.
So the lesson for this weekend is...
- Be a good husband.
(laughing)
- Do something good for the wife.
Okay, what was your lesson?
- Or just do something
nice for somebody, maybe?
You know, like wives
can do very nice things
for their husbands too.
- I make you yummy food.
- I think that's very important.
- Who will cook, cookie--
- Who will cookie?
- Who will cook you yummy food every day?
- She does have yummy
food, you can check out
her YouTube channel, there's
some good stuff on there.
Alright, thank you guys for joining us
in this impromptu amazing short video.
We believe in you, we hope you continue to
believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is--
- We'll see you soon!
- You got to say much love.
- [Both] Much love!
- And we'll see you soon.
- We'll see you soon.